Wow whoa whoa oh I can't stop burping
[Music]
hi we're the try and Eugene we're in New
York City and I'm Keith and I'm Zack and
we're here in sunny Los Angeles New York
is known for having the best pizza in
the world we're gonna try and find the
best slice of the city and la is known
for having the worst New York style
pizza we're gonna try and find the very
worst in it's a dry guy let's go well my
family's New York Italian and my
grandfather would always take me to
pizza places these are the factors we're
gonna be judging the pizza on geez geez
that doesn't stretch something that can
withstand a hit crust crust it is just
like chewy but you don't want it to it
off I'm terrible sauce just like right
out of a jar just garbage and the New
York back what the New York the wow
factor what's especially bad to forget
about it though is it good if I zero
forget about it's as good will you
remember it yes the New York office
where can you find the best slice of
pizza and got over a hundred responses
but some topics emerged we are at our
first stop Lombardi's widely considered
the original New York pizzeria and we
have a special guest joining us all
right let's go inside
because when the crust is this cheese
+14 stringiness that's off is still with
me
my boss has a really good life we've
been waiting clutter has a woody crunch
to it
forget about back to zero I love about
this I wonder what people's back are
doing right now
[Music]
Wow boys that looks really weird outside
of Greco's two and a half stars out of a
hundred and twenty nine reviews date of
stale and distasteful that's like
attitude not even play probably would
pizza let's do this this looks bad okay
well this crust is like hard hard I feel
like I'm eating raw dough oh I don't
taste any cheese or sauce it's almost a
whisper of sauce it tastes like anything
it tastes like a mistake it's amazing
how little flavor a feed could have
that's the wow for me time to check back
with you Jen and then in New York but
first a quick rice break
[Music]
back to you and you are can get in
Eugene I don't get any service in the
same way what's with that it's
Underground
right now we're at John's of Bleecker
Street it's got graffiti all on the
walls it's a sit-down place that's a
little more casual yeah kind of like a
pizza diner yeah yeah yeah so let's
check it out yeah cuz my hair's melting
because they are so high all right let's
go inside gets people cheers I get a
bonus plus one for grease cheese super
Polly public cheese sauce a really
strong tomato flavor on the sauce yes
this delicious though it's kind of cool
we won't forget about it I would I would
remember 20 million remember balance
confusing can you do your best do York
accent wow what a time you seem to be
having well we walked down the street to
another pizza place combo it's worst
pizza ever pizza we can do this we
brought our friend Chris yeah he knows
mediocre food best Chris what do you
know about compost pizza absolutely
nothing great is it's actually nicer
than the last place
yeah it's pretty thank you so much take
care of
hey squeeze what you call this Chris I
agree school gnarly this one makes me
feel bad it's taste like some school
pizza this is as doughy if not dough
your than the first one over here this
is yellow sandy let's take up under the
crust yeah it's just burnt bread the WoW
of this is that it gets worse as a
cookie this is more memorably awful than
the first one they'll be feeling queasy
now you guys check in with Eugene and
Ned who are having the way better time
they're doing something crazy guys I
just got sick
our next stop we're outside Joe's pizza
this place was opened in 1975 and Joe
apparently still works and runs this
place and there's one location york
really has a good hold on family and
traditional and forget it forget about a
few pieces and some chicken in and I'm
feeling gross yeah I feel really quite
like garbage looks so good everything's
like really greasy what I imagine my
head right yeah like I might already
have to poop from that pizza choose
exceptionally straining real strong pulp
actor sauce actually not quite there you
guys look like you're having a great
time so much fun a little bit burnt but
not too lightly burn toast
how many forget about we give it see
what forget about it I tried to poop but
I couldn't but I feel like I have to you
looked at pizza in the dictionary this
would be a photo of it
imagine with a $2.00 50-cent pizza in LA
would taste like
oh I guess verbing not burping we're
going through the Grove to the farmers
market at the Grove that's where we were
told that the pizza is okay here we are
this look terrible the crust looks
pretty good yeah and there's like a nice
distribution of peps but sees life
becomes liquid immediately but the
flavor isn't bad I'm not gonna lie I'm
pretty disappointed this is pretty good
cheese's stretchy the sauce is tasty the
crust was good the wow factor is it's
not bad it's supposed to be bad Wow is
Wow
I could eat this to you in New York it's
time to FaceTime Zach and key
I don't have service so what's the moral
of the story do you guys think that you
found a far worse place than we found
the best place well I'd say that the
second place was easier the worst
present ever had all the pieces we had
where x1 including this two brothers
[Music]
finding a truly atrocious and horrible
slice of pizza and in Los Angeles heard
them we thought it was gonna be but
still we tried and we're the try guys so
what will we try the eggs I miss our
friends I hope they come back soon I'm
gonna jump into LA
Pizza Pizza Pizza Pizza Pizza Pizza
Pizza Pizza